bonjour je m'appelle Virginie Legrand je
suis chef à domicile dans
l'Île-de-France et aujourd'hui je vous
présente une recette de saison originale
et très colorée ce sont des palais de
butternut avec du foie gras poêlé on y
va
[Musique]
le butternut on est en pleine saison des
cucurbitacées là je j'ai fait des
tranches je les ai emporte-pièces en
fait et après je les ai blanchi
c'est-à-dire que je les ai passé 10
minutes à l'eau et là je vais les
poignets au beurre
[Musique]
on va passer maintenant à la cuisson du
foie gras poêlé évidemment pas besoin de
remettre de l'huile et du beurre parce
que le foie gras c'est gras
[Musique]
je vais couper
les morceaux dans ce cas là
je concasse
mes baies roses
[Musique]
j'ai détaillé mes suprêmes d'orange il
faut que vous enleviez toute la partie
blanche de la grume pour que vous ne
récoltiez finalement que l'essentiel
[Musique]
j'ai
du sel à la truffe
pour la déco c'est de la de la pistache
concassée les petites baies roses
framboises qui sont les dernières
la petite astuce c'est quand vous avez
fait cuire vos escalopes de foie gras
pensez bien à les éponger sur du papier
absorbant sinon votre assiette sera
remplie de gras et ce ne sera ni joli ni
bon appétit